wir müssen jetzt endlich was ist das
gebündelte soziale netzwerk und welches
ist das ungewöhnlichste das haben
forscherinnen und forscher darauf wie
oft public health der königlichen
gesellschaft für die öffentliche
gesundheit in großbritannien jetzt
herausgefunden liebe fragen über 1500
britische jugendliche und kamen zu
leider eher schlechten bewertungen der
plattform und es gab eine positive
wartung krieg zum seitenwechsel konnte
erst mal die gute nachricht nicht alle
sozialen medien machen uns krank sondern
es gibt auch viele positive seiten zu
bieten die sozialen medien zugang zu
wissen emotionaler unterstützung für
minderheiten wie können sich dort finden
und austauschen
sie helfen bei der selbstentfaltung und
identitätsbildung und unterstützen mann
finden von beziehung aber es gibt eben
auch eine menge schlechte eigenschaften
die forscherinnen und forscher ließen
die jugendlichen für jede plattform die
eigenschaften auf einer skala von minus
eins bis plus 1 bewerten dabei waren die
negativen eigenschaften unter anderem
schlafentzug ein negatives körperbild
cyber mobbings und forbo also vier of
missing out die angst das beste zu
verbannen
durch all diese positiven und negativen
eigenschaften ergeben sich konsequenzen
für unsere psyche und die müssen wir im
auge behalten zitat socialmedia wurden
zu einem raum in dem der beziehungen
bilden unsere identität form und
umsetzer wirkliches wesentlich mit
unserer psyche verbunden und das können
wir nicht länger ignorieren sagt die
studienleiterin völlig krämer sie folgen
will zum beispiel dass jeder sechste
jugendliche unter angstzuständen leidet
in den letzten 25 jahren ist das sogar
um 70 prozent gestiegen sieht eine
sozialen medien sagen die befragten die
meisten plattformen bewerten die
jugendlichen bei der befragung negativ
und am schlechtesten kam dabei achtung
trommelwirbel instagram beck die
fotoplattform erfolgten innerhalb
komplexer und die inhalte produzieren
ein körperbild zumindest fragwürdig ist
die forscherinnen und forscher winter
ansicht dass das schädlich für das
empfindliche setz bewusstsein von
teenagern es lieber ins netz fitter und
facebook spielt bei instagram vor eine
große rolle
und was alle plattform gemeinsam haben
schlafmangel ist und der ist während des
heranwachsens eine plattform wurden
durch die bank eher negative wertes ist
auf eine und die mit abstand achtung
wiederum trommelwirbel
youtube ja hier überwogen die folge
siegen einschätzungen deutlich vor ist
zum beispiel viel weniger ausgeprägt die
inhalte werden als emotionale
unterstützung empfunden selbstentfaltung
und identi selbstbildung werden wir
absolut positiv gesehen
youtube macht nicht einsam einen
jugendlichen sondern im gegenteil trägt
verbindung von communitys beim schlafen
da sieht es ähnlich schlimm wie bei den
anderen plattformen aus und vor allem
für die empfehlen die forscher und
forscherinnen die kennzeichnung von
photoshop die bildern software die die
nutzerinnen und nutzer darauf aufmerksam
macht wenn sie zu viel und zu spät am
smartphone oder computer hängen
algorithmen die auf bestimmte wörter und
inhalte reagieren und zum beispiel
selbsthilfegruppen und professionelle
hilfe empfehlen zudem sollten das thema
soziale medien öfter und besser zum
thema machen und sozialarbeiter sollten
lernen mit den sozialen medien in ihren
algorithmen umzugehen um bessere
reichweiten also ich kann mich
jedenfalls nur der positiven bewertung
von youtube baden schließen leute schaut
mehr youtube ich kann mich dabei super
unterstützen wenn er mir hier ein abo
aufs auge drückt und nicht dem auf die
glocke vegetiert geht es direkt weiter
mit dem video über die bedrohung der
menschheit durch künstliche intelligenz
draufklicken von klicks um wien
schwarzen würde ich mal sagen und
ansonsten bislang bekannt